ti faccio fare qualcosa a bomba quelle
quelle sono pazzesche 3 floris stupito
che numero ai jonathan mi puoi portare
il 41 della air force ai black leather
medal white sugar bomba caro per
scrupolo che ho preso anche la 43a così
non sta mai proprio guarda queste c'è
questo non solo delle sorelle questo
materasso ortopedico per il tuo piede
cioè ieri ho fatto duomo duomo rho a
piedi e ho avuto sotto due pesci che ci
ha capito mi hanno salvato la vita c'è
questo e proprio guarda guarda la
flessibilità al confort ruoli così
comunque bova che stanno perfetti ma
come cose la città diodato mi che ti
faccio scelgono i lacci bianchi lo vedo
se tutto preciso tutto stiloso
ovviamente c'è anche la promozione paghi
5 prendi due ci ha capito lo sono perché
se tu diventò anche lo spray perché se
non ostuzzi sopra appena più a questi
bagnano questo con balsamo labbra per le
scarpe pro tranquillo ho già messo tutto
dentro calzini scarpe solette e spray fa
sola casa libri auto piace fogli di
giornale che faccio di don che una busta